[Music]
it's almost the weekend yeah
almost the weekend
clap away
my little friends happy friday everyone
well it's been a good week and a bad one
legendary writer and humorist pj
o'rourke passed away it sucks but he was
kind enough before he went to leave so
much behind for all of us and not just
cigar butts and empty whiskey bottles
which sounds like the name of cat's
autobiography
he left us some amazing books like
parliament of [ __ ]
modern manners and the one that changed
me republican party reptile which is now
liz cheney's nickname
he also gave us two of the greatest
pieces of satire ever written the
national lampoon 1964 high school
yearbook and the sunday newspaper parody
o'rourke was one of the greatest editors
of one of the greatest magazines ever
national lampoon he may not have written
animal house but he lived it he made it
happen
and he made me happen too
okay you can't win them all but he gave
me hope and he gave me a path a place to
go for someone who didn't fit in really
anywhere i bring this up tonight because
what we're seeing in today's culture is
in part pj's legacy
what he did for the right is make it
okay for them to be wrong in the best
sense of the word to be funny to be
loose to be high to be horny which
sounds like the name of my autobiography
he told us he told us it's okay to be
alive which was everything the
stereotype of the right was not
we didn't always have to be stayed or
stiff or judgmental and you didn't have
to seed culture to the left the left had
their abbey hoffmans and their merry
pranksters and o'rourke said they might
be onto something and then came andrew
breitbart our married prankster so irk's
thesis was simple politics ruins
everything so fight back with fun
when i was younger i wrote a piece
called the dean wermer effect based on
this fella from the movie animal house
0.2
fat drunk and stupid is no way to go
through life son you're out
finished at faber expelled i want you
off this campus at nine o'clock monday
morning ugh love him
i noted that's john vernon i noted that
in every narrative the framework always
stayed the same we republicans were
always dean wermer and the dems were
animal house the cheerful troublemakers
the wise guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so in every situation the right had a
stick up their ass
meanwhile the left had a joint in their
mouths
my goal was to flip that script to
reverse the dean wermer effect and my
inspiration was pj he made it clear that
to fight politics the weapon was always
going to be fun and now it's happening
the big flip
we're having fun
they aren't it's driving them crazy and
we really didn't have to lift a finger
and when we do thanks to pj it's always
the middle one
all it took was a little trump and a lot
of wokism donald trump showed us that we
could be as obnoxious
funny and feisty as they are and win now
pj was definitely no fan of trump but
trump was all animal house and no dean
wermer he was more like rodney
dangerfield's character in caddyshack
americans no longer had to choose
between robotic helmet-haired hillary
clinton or robotic helmet-haired mitt
romney
somehow a loud mouth billionaire from
queens taught republicans how to have a
good time in an instant we found
ourselves laughing at the hapless cnn
which became a gibbering dean wermer in
fact their entire lineup became a string
of minor wormers shrieking all as well
while the real world ran them over
and now wokeness came along and turned a
once tolerant democratic party into a
political version of jonestown adhere to
an ideology or die
the party that once said keep the
government out of my bedroom is now the
party that forces men to bring their
lawyer with them on a date
the party that once advocated for a
colorblind society now sees pigment but
nothing else the party that was
pro-women now replaces moms with
birthing persons
so the dams aren't an all-out panic
because voters now think their party is
too preachy and judgmental probably from
the constant preaching and judging
the brand is now more toxic than a cup
of drano that's wokism political drano
they're so puritanical they make jerry
falwell look like gene simmons
the democratic party is now as
repressive as a bag full of ayatollahs
as wokism has sucked the fun out of
everything
i had a friend who in order to lose
weight would eat some of his meal and
then empty an ashtray on the rest it
worked he stopped eating and it ruined
everyone's everyone else's appetite too
that's what wokism has done to the
democratic party but also to women's
sports awards shows disney our justice
system it's an ashtray loaded with
carcinogenic orthodoxy
because it can create all it does is
destroy it's a political construct that
forces humans to comport to unnatural
demands that may be fun in bed but not
in politics it pretended to be about
tolerance intimidating a party through
threats of cancellation
obey or they will ruin you using social
media and its media accomplices
like your wife's driving their success
was based on scaring you
not convincing you
so why make a good argument when you can
have rioters burning businesses in media
hacks doxing private citizens for
speaking the truth
that that's how they took over the
democratic party then like brian stelter
trapped in a frito-lay warehouse they
eat everything from the inside
it's funny
and cheap i would say the dems are dean
wermer but right now it's worse
it's reagan from the exorcist
yeah the party's a child possessed by a
demon which definitely needs an exorcism
because if it doesn't happen soon
they're toast
voters deserve more than the bad ideas
they barf up like so much split pea soup
i'd like to help but frankly i'm having
too good a time and for that i'd like to
say thank you pj
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest she cause andrew
cuomo more pain than his rusty nipple
ring fox news senior meteorologist
judith dude
he's so patriotic he sleeps with his
hand over his heart oklahoma
transportation commissioner and former
oklahoma speaker of the house t.w
shannon
and her blood type is mojito fox news
contributor cat tim
and when there's an earthquake san
andreas says it's his fault
that's cute my massive sidekick in the
nwa's world television champion
tyrus
janice how are you i'm good good that's
good to see you and good to see everyone
i'm so glad i got to see tyrus because
it's been i'm a big fan of you my pound
for pound bigger food
wow how sweet maybe we should just call
it a day you guys
i'm your fan too greg yeah well thank
you for watching thank you that was chat
who you got to pick
danistina greg obviously i have janice
oh bam oh
look at her we've been getting a lot of
mail about how we should be changing up
the co-host thing
crazy because we get the same letters
about the host
i think he'd be a pretty good co-host
yeah yeah give some time off for cats
you agree janice
i'm not offended i could do some weather
yes um
have you noticed the shift do you do you
see do you look at what i'm talking
about this theory of the shift that it's
taking place of course and i think moms
are going to change the world by the way
i really feel that you know don't mess
with our kids should be a hashtag
for the midterms because what's
happening in schools uh what's happening
with our kids uh you know moms are
starting to rise up they're going to the
meetings they're saying we're not going
to take it anymore and when one mom
stands up and says something the other
moms behind stand up as well and i think
now more than ever
there's a revolution of moms wanting
change in this country it's funny
because generally activists and
protesters don't have kids which gives
them the free time so it's like when you
say when you see a like a parent that's
protesting that's actually a lot of work
like date night yeah yeah it is
the shift is happening you can see it
greg even uh you know it used to be when
you just disagreed with liberals they
would just consider you unenlightened
not that smart not that informed right
if you disagree with conservatives we
just considered you godless right i mean
that's the way it was exactly now it's
completely different not only do
liberals consider you not to be worthy
intellectually but they also think that
you have a moral deficit if you don't
agree with me in lockstep 100
then there's something wrong with your
morality you know that's the reason they
called every american a white
supremacist they called everybody who
disagreed with them uh some everything
but an american and unfortunately uh or
fortunately for us i think they're gonna
get rewarded uh at the ballot box this
midterm republicans are going to see a
huge wave uh because of the way the woke
left has chosen to go it is like there
is this weird it is a um what's the word
i'm looking for a
a pendulum so what tw is talking about
is that like okay so when we were not
even born let's say the 50s we always
heard about a repressive 50s culture
that it was a moralism a puritanical
obsessed with moral behavior
that directly applies to woke-ism that
is the new religion that is why they're
obsessed with behavior they want
everybody to come to comport to the
things that they believe is morally true
even though it's kind of a
it's kind of an amoral life well
in the 50s it was backed by like
stringent religious beliefs right and
now it's backed by
fantasy beliefs or what sounds good in
the think tank yeah and if i could just
this week yeah this week what i'm saying
is forever changing yeah but i wouldn't
we have seen a big change and honestly i
think you started it i think janice dean
started because no one ever
whenever the democrats or whenever that
that left liberal group was challenged
it just didn't happen people did not
challenge them because they were always
on the right side of everything they
live with their heart and your challenge
over what happened with your family
has changed things to where now we're
seeing more people are willing to fight
against the liberal left before they was
worth it because you just didn't get hit
conservatives don't like you what you
have to sit in the back of a church puke
yeah you know what i'm saying or you
don't get to wear a tie but when the
democrats and liberals don't like you
you can't go to a concert you can't
worry about you can't you can't do
anything
your your social media are attacked by
everybody and i i think
we can't when history looks back at when
this thing changed you're going to be at
the front of it because right you
started to where people started going
you know what there's no reason to be
afraid right is right you don't want to
put up with an angry wokester because
they'll go on social media they will
create mobs also they'll they'll they
have the time to just make your life a
living hell they'll come to your house
they'll come to your house so that's
what that's what shut up that's what
shut up the democrats so they couldn't
even go after this stuff but then then
you have you know uh um
janice
i almost called you dana see how bad it
is that's okay that's a huge comment oh
stop it it is um
i'm kidding um but uh but it's like when
somebody stands up it makes it easier
for everybody else to stand up cat
what do you think of this
you've been targeted before yeah well
it's really actually crazy because okay
i'm not a republican i'm not a democrat
i am a mostly lawless heathen right yes
so it's crazy that i actually feel more
comfortable
to you know that i can say things in a
room full of conservatives than in a
room full of leftists of course which is
which is crazy given the fact that i am
a lawless heathen yes right i'm
terrified when i'm in a room full of
leftists and they ask me any questions
like where do you work
i just gotta leave yeah
they will chase you out i just have to
say you know what i'm going to go home
but i think you can also see this
when you think of like lawless heathens
like cat
you see it on bill maher's face every
friday
he's looking at he's he saw this coming
that when he looks at the other side
trump was having fun his rallies were
having fun people were laughing and his
audience wasn't his audience was in
lockstep and he was fed up with it
that's why you see him distancing
himself from his own party's hostilities
and wokism and you're going to keep
seeing that now with i think a lot of
other maybe vocal democrats because they
turn on them yeah because he's he's not
part of them anymore yeah hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else